karine béchir gologo professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france que symbolise cette
séquence que nous venons de vivre à
l'instant un jour il est vrai que malgré
les circonstances il a été absolument
fondamental de marquer cette journée du
9 mai qui pour le peuple russe n'est pas
une date anodine est pas une fête parmi
d'autres une célébration parmi d'autres
le 9 mai comme le président poutine l'a
mis en avant c'est effectivement l'image
de l'âme du peuple russe est aussi en
quelque sorte le bouclier du monde
russes donc il est absolument
inconcevable en quoi qu'il se passe de
ne pas marquer cette date surtout lors
des 75 ans de la capitulation de
l'allemagne nazie doux si vous voulez
c'est cette mise en avant à la fois de
de cette volonté d'affirmer de
réaffirmer le rôle fondamental joué par
l'armée rouge
dans la seconde guerre mondiale puisque
rappelons le le rôle reste encore est de
plus en plus contestée par le clan
atlantis qui cherche à récupérer en
quelques sortes à cette victoire de la
seconde guerre mondiale de monopoliser
quand il s'agissait réellement si vous
voulez d'une victoire du des alliés de
l'urss ensemble contre l'allemagne nazie
est fondamental que la russie garde
vivante la mémoire de ce que les soldats
de l'armée rouge trophées ont libéré que
la moitié de l'europe
seuls ont libéré encore d'autres pays
avec l'aide d'armes et locales c'est un
tribut que l'histoire doit leur payer
éternellement
il n'est pas anecdotique en ce rôle à
jouer notamment par les manuels
est-ce que de votre point de vue il a
participé aussi à la construction d'une
certaine perception de la russie tout à
fait il faut bien comprendre que après
la seconde guerre mondiale et avec le
renforcement l'installation
l'instauration pour un des décennies de
la guerre froide la france avait partie
d'un clan le clan américain est en ce
sens là tout le discours a été réécrit
l'histoire d'un peuple c'est aussi le
discours de la vie de ce peuple
les manuels d'histoire vont conditionner
la perception des enfants donc c'est un
travail à long terme de petit à petit
les générations compte avoir des visions
trucs et reconstruite ré écrite du
discours national conformément à
l'intérêt de certains groupes
géopolitiques la france le problème est
qu'elle a mis en quelque sorte elle
s'est mise entre les mains d'une
puissance perdant elle même en ce sens
du coup sa puissance puisqu'elle ne peut
plus écrire n'a plus la maîtrise de son
discours national à côté des manuels
d'histoire vous avez souligné être juste
titre à toute la machine d'hollywood qui
se met en place
combien de films soviétiques sont
montrés en france et fils soviétiques
sont d'une qualité absolument
exceptionnelle il y à une présentation
humaine équilibré sans aucune caricature
de la période de la guerre et aucun de
ses films quasiment ne sont montrés en
france autant les français peuvent citer
des réalisateurs américains des acteurs
américains conduits en plaques cité des
réalisateurs soviétique des acteurs
politiques
cela montre un partage du monde ce qui
explique ce renversement total
la première génération a vécu la guerre
elle connaît la réalité elle a vécu dans
sa chair
donc elle reconnaît naturellement le
rôle de l'urss
maintenant nous sommes une génération
qui n'a pas connu la guerre elle ne
connaît que le discours sur la guerre ce
discours a été totalement réécrit la
culture joue beaucoup on comprend
comment aussi l'ordre international qui
a été établie après 1945 comment est-ce
que
a construit selon vous les relations
internationales vis-à-vis de la russie
je pense qu'il faut différencier de
choses l'ordre tel qu'issu de la de la
seconde guerre mondiale a partagé le
monde entre deux puissances la puissance
américaine
d'un côté la puissance soviétique de
l'autre avec la chute de l'urss
le problème se pose pour la russie
juridiquement naturellement la russie et
la continuatrice de l'urss
ça ne se discute pas celui sur le plan
juridique le problème est que tous ne
s'explique pas par le droit et de
manière très symbolique par exemple à aa
il y a eu une interruption des parades
militaires entre 91 et 95
la russie n'a pas fait de parade
militaire après la chute de l'urss
la domination américaine en russie alors
était un militaire mais idéologiquement
extrêmement fortes dans ce cas là il n'y
avait pas de place pour revendiquer le
rôle de l'armée rouge dans la seconde
guerre mondiale ce monde global ne
permet qu'un seul centre politique c'est
le succès les états unis le monde
attentiste en tout cas parce qu'avec 36
boutiques un petit peu mais il n'y avait
pas de place en tout cas sous les pour
un autre homme politique la russie avec
le temps est revenu sur la scène
internationale et elle revendique une
certaine place je vous faire très
attention aux symboles parce qu'il est
très long de les mettre en place
il est très facile de les détruire c'est
pour ça que pour le président poutine
dit qu' il y aura des célébrations
importantes
une parade militaire pour les 75 ans la
capitulation et il y aura un régiment
immortel c'est à espérer que
effectivement ça aura lieu et cela aura
lieu de façon importante pour montrer si
vous voulez également ce partage des
rôles et l'existence politique de la
russie sur la scène géopolitique puisque
les crises sanitaires à n'enlève rien au
combat géopolitique qui semaine
doyon en cours tous les jours merci
beaucoup karine avait chez goal of que
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
invité à l'université d'état de moscou